first of all how are you guys enjoying
your day of speed dating
oh it's been it's been great what have
you been thinking about talking to 1 000
people
in two hours matilda the same thing's
been getting a lot of the same questions
steve the gauntlet has been thrown you
cannot ask the same questions that
matilda has answered for the past
i think it's six hours now um okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna give it a shot and i
can't wait
we love a new question right tilly yeah
we do
um okay so i'm gonna start with uh
hypothetically speaking i i know that
neither of you would steal anything from
a movie set
but would you happen to have borrowed
anything from the set of this movie
where you planned on bringing it back
but you just never did
that is a new question i have two did
you get anything matilda or no
ah did i did you take a shirt you take
one of your shirts
wait yes i
i took some of my costumes they get
because they had like
so many extras they had so many extras
of the shirt so they were like hey you
want to take
you want to take one of these you want
to take one of those yes
i took the keychain which was a hobbes
type
keychain for george i not took
uh tyler props who was lovely gave it to
me and then i took
my i took my binders keeper's uh name
card thing
there we go have either of you seen ex
machina
yes i can't i hope matilda has not well
you know something this is a question uh
for you ben because i'm i'm by steve
you're two for two
we haven't heard either of these
questions so far so far you're nailing
it um so my question is with the
in this movie in the store that you're
showing the name tag from if you would
show it up again
binders keepers right um there is a
sequence in the movie where you are
dancing
on camera and i'm just curious when you
start dancing on camera in a movie how
much are you in your head
thinking about how awesome oscar was in
ex machina
when he was dancing it could never be
matched that dance routine is like
gorgeous and smooth and amazing and then
you see my dance routine and it is very
much not that
it is literally like we were just
dancing and then lina's like all right
what about something in this aisle i was
like sure
okay let's do something weird in this
aisle great um but that was so funny
because those are the type of uh
because that's like for my character he
starts to believe in himself a bit more
and he starts to like
show it through dancing a bit and um i
love watching that stuff
in movies so the fact that i got to do
one of those and i'm like oh making a
dance montage i can't believe it this is
i'm so excited
uh so that was very exciting for me i
love the way the movie opens
with like the silver surfer joke the
wolverine comic book
um i i love i mean it's a great way to
bring people in
uh and i'm just curious for both of you
do you have a favorite comic
or was there one joke in the movie or
one reference you really enjoyed
i love spider-man growing up i loved
x-men
uh spider-man was big to me though
because he was a new york kid who was
funny
as well as being a superhero but i mean
i loved marvel when i was a kid i had
all the cards
i collected a ton of the comics so
spiderman was a big one for me was there
a line or something in the movie tilly
that you love is there a certain line
that you're like oh this one it's so fun
to say a line
i feel like there were a few ones where
it it gave me some joy i mean like the
holy unanticipated occurrences was
actually really fun to say
and holy begun but you know those those
kinds of lines were fun
uh matilda i'm going to give you a lot
of credit and say that you were
fantastic in the movie i really enjoyed
your performance
i'm curious uh where and when did you
find out that you landed this role
because i heard there was like a
thousand people that tried to get it
yeah so it's strange how i actually
found out well not really kind of
so i was in the middle of times square
and there were so many people everywhere
pre-pandemic of course um and i was
i got a phone call from my on my mom's
phone
and it was from alina and i
i got i put it up to my ear and i could
barely hear her
and she said hey magilda you want to be
in this movie and i was like
yes and i started jumping around
everywhere and i was so excited
my mom actually has a video oh is that
true
yeah oh please tell your mom to text me
that video
yeah i will okay great uh there is a
i'm for both of you i think a lot of
people who are going to watch
this interview there's going to be
people that really don't understand how
movies are made
for each of you uh can you share
something that might surprise people to
learn
about actually making a movie things
that maybe they wouldn't know
sure what do you think this was your
first ever movie when you went on
set what did you realize they're like
whoa i didn't know it's this
i kind of knew a lot of this stuff
because my dad's an actor so i
i wasn't surprised about much but some a
fact that
i didn't know like i found out watching
a movie once
uh was that movies are filmed out of
order and
i didn't know that and yeah
yeah that's a big one i think that's a
good call also i think people will be
if someone visits set they're going to
realize how boring it is some people are
like oh my goodness it's going to be
like every minute everybody's
but you know matilda and i go on camera
do five takes and if they have to turn
the camera around let's say it was on
matilda it's going to be on me
that's going to be 35 minutes so that
matilda and i are just like
playing games with each other like you
know doing just wasting time there's
if any anytime a friend of mine comes to
set which is almost never
um they're like whoa so this is this is
it
it's like hey you do this and then you
wait and then you do this then you wait
and then you do this then you wait
there's a lot of waiting
um and i think people would be really
surprised how much actual
acting you do and how much waiting to
get ready for acting you do
uh this will probably be my last
question and by the way i'm feeling so
much pressure to not
ever see that this is your last question
ever in your career
oh my goodness oh my goodness
listen i know that you guys must have
had a lot of fun making this movie
when you think back on the shoot what's
like a dare or two that you will
remember forever
i think that car chase scene was really
fun saying goodbye to tilly was very sad
we that was i remember that one uh
saying goodbye to you that i found that
to be very sad because we had such a
good time and we became such good
friends
and then it was just over then it's just
over and you go back to your
respective cities yeah um that i
remember that day very well
what other one do you think oh and i had
to hang off the side of a building that
was terrifying
i will not forget that yeah that took a
while we did like so many takes for that
that was terrifying for someone who's
afraid of heights um what about you
tilly what's
some of the stuff you remember i feel
like all of them were actually really
fun to film
like every scene was so exciting and fun
so uh i think i have to go on that note
but i'm gonna say that i'm looking
forward to space for season two
hey and something called station 11
which is right up my alley and way more
adult than uh this movie
matilda started on broadway in a way
more adult thing and she's going back to
a way more adult thing for station 11.
on that note seriously congrats i know
that's going to be a big hit for you
guys
families are going to love it thanks
steve i appreciate it man
have a great day talk to you again you
didn't repeat any questions
i know you did great i'm so proud of you
steve
i can't believe it you know what i mean
i'm rooting for you from the beginning i
was rooting for you it looks like by the
way it's hard
you're the beta max what do you have
behind you oh yeah
beta sp you're doing great buddy now by
the way i can't believe you knew what
that was